it's great using your platform in that
way a hundred percent I agree with you
and that's what I admire so much about
Joe to be honest it's like
yeah Joe's man he's literally
he is is cool even if you're a fan as
cool as you think he is you don't really
understand what he did because like when
he puts a guy like me on his podcast
that could bomb you know how many Comics
he'll put on and I'm sure the episodes
don't do as well but he's doing it
because those people are hilarious and
he feels that people should see them
most people when they get power they
don't like to give it away like George
is on some like I mean I mean that Joe's
on something like George Washington like
it's crazy to to to be president and be
like all right I gotta stop this
you know what I mean like I Gotta Give
power back to the people that's a weird
thing Marcus Aurelius philosopher king
Loki low-key so it's like
yeah it's it's just a benevolent a
benevolent King is the rarest one and we
got it and we gotta appreciate it while
while it's it's here because it's not
always going to be here because usually
what the thing inside people that makes
them want to get power is the thing that
will make them not want to relinquish
any of it correct yeah I mean you're
totally right I never even thought of it
but there could be another world in
which the biggest podcaster in the world
also happened to be a total
that will be the case
most likely at some point after Joe
retires
forever yeah like like this is the
anomaly yeah you know what I mean like I
I honestly it's so weird and that's so
that's kind of like every you know
everybody has your North Stars like my
father's my North Star in like most
situations like I'm just like what would
he do like how would he treat the people
around him how would he Empower them how
would he do that and I look at other
people that also do that and I'm like
you know he's a great example especially
in the entertainment business about how
you could put people on yeah and how you
could put people on and that doesn't
hurt you that just makes you that much
better like Loki I look at Drake like
that too like Drake gave so many people
features and then made them famous
because of those features that didn't
make Drake any less but what it did do
is made every one of those artists so
grateful of Drake
so now
anytime Drake needs anything they're
there any anybody says anything about
Drake they're like nah [ __ ] you that guy
made me a millionaire yeah my mom a
house yeah like he didn't have to simply
because he loved my art how he's done
his career how Joe's it's also no
[ __ ]
yeah it's it's it's it's not surprising
at all that you look at the people that
are at the top of their careers or like
their top of their Industries and
they're operating in a kind of similar
way which is who like point I'm just
saying Drake and Rogan like yes pointing
out these people who are far less famous
and successful than them and then giving
them the platform to be successful Drake
Will Go On Your Song
he's not even saying be on my [ __ ] he's
going I'm going on your [ __ ]
you know what I mean like that's crazy
like I asked Jose yo will you be the
first guest on the Pod he's like
absolutely yeah
and you never want to ask somebody you
know is that busy but it was one of
those things where it's like we also
want to kind of honor him a little bit
you know what I mean it's like I think
it's only like a shrine yeah like yo man
like you're so instrumental in even
making this so that's the thing like I
think that's why also there's so many
people that'll defend Joe no matter what
what anybody says about him this was the
interesting thing that I realized around
a bunch of the different controversies
that happened over the last year with
him
what happens usually when the Press
brings up a particular news story is
they say this is the tip of the iceberg
that shows this particular person is the
homophobic racist transphobic
misogynistic piece of [ __ ] that we've
always said that there were yeah now the
problem with Joe for the Press was even
a casual fan has listened to like 200 to
500 hours and there's people that have
listened to multiple thousands of hours
and they go yeah you're telling us that
this is the tip of the iceberg
I've seen the whole Iceberg yeah I know
that there's nothing down there exactly
so for you to
besmirch and like smear this person's
name by claiming you know something I
don't yeah I don't think you do yeah
yeah that's what that's what was so I
think what is so good it's such a good
protectionist strategy and it's not a
strategy but it's just a byproduct of
talking for hundreds and hundreds of
hours every single year it's like look
if I [ __ ] genuinely didn't like black
people yeah it would be out there by now
people would know how [ __ ] good of an
actor do you think I am yeah to be able
to hold this non-racist persona for like
[ __ ] thousands and thousands of hours
yeah and the craziest thing is he's
vegan that's the thing a lot of people
don't know like that elk [ __ ] is a lie
like Beyond elk it's beyond elk it's
he's he's a very strict vegan like
strict vegan and can't use a crossbow
for [ __ ] I was like yo show me how to do
that bow and arrow [ __ ] tiny foreskin
dude can't crossbow those are the things
you gotta attack them for those are the
every one of those is CGI the crossbow
[ __ ] CGI like he uses he takes a scooter
to work like a Razor scooter to work
he's just doing like every single day
that's I don't know why they don't
attack him for that they always come for
these old videos and that kind of stuff
but you got a vegan on a Razor scooter
that can't even use a cross bro you know
like that's the thing that you should
probably write a New York Times article
about you know isn't that crazy like
when you go you know how you've done the
Pod and he's just like you know mashing
down Beyond Burgers like he's like this
is soy like you know how he tries to rub
soy on your tits right before every pot
like that's that's my favorite part I'm
gonna wipe it off the microphone before
you again yeah yeah [ __ ] dude I I uh
now he's a [ __ ] man dude I think it's
very
scary what happens if if and when he
like bows out and somebody else comes
through same thing that happened in L.A
like look at the LA comedy scene when he
was at the helm of L.A Comics everybody
was helping each other out it was this
like beautiful camaraderie that was
happening what's it like now well one I
you know not as many people going out to
the shows and that's reasonable because
you have the most famous person on the
planet that's gonna go to the the comedy
clubs every single week so naturally
you're gonna have people come out there
but
um but yeah just uh it doesn't feel like
there's that same energy that same
excitement that same camaraderie that
was there and I think naturally things
can get a little bit more competitive
people are organizing who's the next
king who's the next person what's the
power of vacuum so there's a power grab
happening of course and uh
but yeah man it's like
yeah that that that potentially can
happen you gotta hope that a guy like
that has instilled enough values in
people that even if they are like these
kind of psychopaths they see that the
way to success is through altruism
kindness support and you've left behind
this like tradition almost yeah so even
though they're using it they're doing
those things for the wrong reason
like it's like even though they they
just being a Christian so they could get
to heaven at least they're being a
Christian moscow's wager again yes
exactly yes you got it right Papa loves
away Pablo's wager I always [ __ ] it up
in other news this episode is brought to
you by whoop it is the best fitness
tracker that I have ever found it's the
only one that I've ever stuck with and
it tracks absolutely everything from my
sleep to my recovery even the workouts
that I do every single day through this
strap which is on 24 7. my resting heart
rate my heart rate variability and even
how much I'm breathing throughout the
night tells me my quality of sleep it
gives me trends and reports over time
but the most important thing is it
actually nudges my behavior through
suggestions in an app it's a digital
coach not just a fitness tracker and it
encourages me to change my behavior that
will improve my health over the long
term even better than that you can join
for free pay nothing for the brand new
whoop 4.0 strap and get your first month
for free so you buy it for free try it
for free and if you do not like it after
29 days they'll give you your money back
head to join.woop.com
modern wisdom to sign up right now
that's join.woop.com
modern wisdom what's happening people if
you enjoyed that then press here for the
full unedited episode and don't forget
to subscribe
peace